[Musica]
chi tra di noi frequenta in qualche modo
la montagna sulle mani
e chi tra di noi vive in montagna
la montagna è bellissima e bellissima
destata per camminarci al fresco
bellissima d'inverno quando la neve
copre tutto
adesso d'autunno con i colori che
esplodono ma viverci
che se la colla di star lassù al freddo
tra quattro gatti e con pochi servizi
è chiaro se se ci sei nato il tuo cuore
appartiene a questi luoghi
oppure magari sei un romantico un no
global in fuga magari mezzo matto
ma altrimenti chi te lo fa fare
perché mai tu che ti consideri una
persona di mondo
non sei nato in montagna non c'è mai
vissuto anche un curriculum che sarebbe
un peccato buttare perché mai tu
dovresti pensare di vivere in montagna
un paio di mesi fa
insieme ad una squadra di
ragazze e ragazzi e un pensionato molto
arzillo e rom in otto
abbiamo concluso una lunga spedizione a
piedi per le montagne di tutto lo
stivale la spedizione va sentiero
la nostra rotta è stata il sentiero
italia pensate il trekking più lungo del
mondo in un paese così piccolo
per 8mila chilometri e sentirò in italia
si
dipana lungo tutte le montagne del paese
dalle alpi agli appennini dal friuli
venezia giulia fino alla sardegna
due anni fa ci siamo messi in cammino
dal golfo di trieste
in 15 mesi con alcune pause anche dovute
alla pandemia abbiamo attraversato
stagioni luoghi situazioni ambienti
completamente diversi dai canyon della
murgia ai monti pallidi a qualche borgo
sperduto dell'aspromonte
ci siamo messi in cammino non per sport
il nostro obiettivo era quello di
rilanciare questo incredibile sentiero
all'epoca semisconosciuto e attraverso
questo viaggio lento
cercare di raccontare cosa sono oggi le
terre alte
chi ci vive
che cosa sono come se si sta che aria si
respira
da questa esperienza
molto
molto intensa
mi sono portato dietro alcune
considerazioni e ce ne sono tre in
particolare che vorrei condividere qui
con voi che in qualche maniera ritengo
utili rispetto alla domanda iniziale
perché mai tu dovresti pensare di vivere
in montagna
in montagna come nella vita
avere una mappa avere una bussola è
fondamentale per non perdersi
io credo però che a volte anche perdersi
possa essere una fortuna e come tale
occorre saperla cogliere
perdersi significa rimanere privi dei
riferimenti quotidiani da cui dipendiamo
e questo a ben guardare ci dà modo di
fuggire alla routine del quotidiano
l'inerzia all'effetto catena di
montaggio perdersi significa rimanere un
po soli spalle al muro alle prese con la
domanda dove devo andare
dove voglio andare
e sei tu
in quest'ottica
perdersi può essere propedeutico a
cercare una direzione non una direzione
qualsiasi ma la tua
alcuni anni fa nel 2016 avevo 29 anni e
per uno di quei momenti esistenziali in
cui per l'appunto ti senti perso
immagino che fa tanti di voi sia
successo lo stesso magari sta succedendo
proprio adesso
per cercare di riordinare le idee o
quantomeno ritardare questo momento
andare a fare un viaggio a piedi tra i
monti della corsica e la
camminando un giorno mi sono perso per
rimanere per rimanere in tema
ero su un altopiano è scesa la nebbia
molto fitta
ho smarrito o la traccia sul terreno
dopo un po mi sono reso conto che stavo
girando in tondo e così cercando di
orientarmi a un certo punto vedo
spuntare da questo muro di nebbia tre
fusti ragazzoni alti biondi tipicamente
scandinavi anche loro con con gli zaini
e anche loro come me si erano persi
nella nebbia
allora abbiamo deciso di cercare insieme
il sentiero e è così chiacchierando a un
certo punto uno di loro si gira e mi fa
ma tu che sei italiano lo conosci
sentiero italia
il sentiero che io non avevo mai sentito
nominare tra la prima volta pensate che
che figuraccia
però quella figuraccia la domanda di
quel ragazzo sbucato a causa della
nebbia sono state in qualche maniera la
scintilla che ha portato me e tutti i
miei compagni ad andarlo a scoprire
questo sentire italia a cercare una
direzione in qualche maniera
se quel giorno di qualche anno fa mi
fossi perso tra i monti della corsica ma
prima ancora un po nella vita adesso
non sarei qui a a parlarvene quindi
morale della favola
se ti perdi approfittano approfittane
per ritrovarti e già che ci sei magari
fatti un giro in montagna che chissà non
porti fortuna
a proposito di
diverso in giro
durante la pandemia
quanto ci è mancato anche solo farci un
giro nel giardino dietro casa nel parco
intrappolate nei nostri appartamentini
come all'improvviso ci siamo resi conto
di quale enorme potere lo spazio
circostante eserciti su di noi
di quanto possa determinare il nostro
umore il nostro vivere quotidiano
abbiamo un po scoperto l'acqua calda
diciamocelo la questione è oggetto di
ricerca già da un po avendo il 50 la
psicologia ambientale indaga proprio il
rapporto tra l'ambiente esterno e
l'ambiente interno quello psichico
in particolare c'è uno studio di rachel
e stephen kharlan che approfondisce le
caratteristiche tournament e deve avere
per risultare stimolante per attivarci
questo ambiente deve essere
armonioso
coerente mappa bile
deve essere ricco di variazioni di forme
di colori di dimensione ricco di spigoli
e di angoli
e così facendo questo ambiente risulterà
complesso e misterioso
queste sono le parole dei kablan
complesso e misterioso ora in base a
questi studi un ambiente del genere
accende il nostro istinto
all'interazione e per questo motivo tali
studi sono applicati soprattutto alla
progettazione degli ambienti di lavoro
per garantire una performance migliore
questo farebbe della montagna un posto
uno scenario ideale non soltanto per
camminare ma per lavorare in teoria ora
passando dalla teoria
alla pratica io finora la montagna non
l'ho vissuta stanzialmente
nondimeno l'ho vissuta a lungo
camminando su e giù lungo la schiena
d'italia in spedizione vedete la nostra
routine era su per giù questa si
camminava chiaramente dalle 6 alle 10
ore 20 25 a volte 30 km con buoni
dislivelli essere in montagna è arrivati
a fine tappa belli su dati ci si dava
una sciacquata e poi via fino a sera
ognuno si trovava un angolino e si
faceva smart working
ognuno tirava fuori il computer il
telefono hot spot e via questo lavoro
che la organizza la logistica chi a
editare le foto i video i social de col
gli articoli la recensione della singola
tappa i partner da gestire così ogni
giorno ora percorrere per correre e
documentare quasi 8.000 km non è uno
scherzo
pensato anche soltanto
cosa significa dormire ogni notte in un
posto diverso
il giorno dopo giorno per mesi e mesi e
mesi
può essere pesante può essere molto
stressante
il sonno arretrato l'acido lattico tutti
gli imprevisti da gestire gli infortuni
l'assenza totale di spazi personali
insomma possono esserci dei crolli
emotivi anche importanti ne abbiamo
avuti e come a volte non ci siamo anche
parlati per giorni se non in una
settimana
e d'altra parte ho mai fatto qualcosa di
così estremo però in qualche modo siamo
sempre andate avanti fino alla fine
qualcosa ci ha stimolati a proseguire a
marciare sotto il sole sotto la pioggia
in qualche modo a portare avanti a
termine il nostro lavoro passando anche
attraverso una una pandemia globale
penso che chiaramente la nostra
determinazione la nostra passione hanno
giocato un ruolo importante però stando
agli studi di cui parlavamo anche
l'ambiente circostante
ha giocato la sua parte e cioè la
montagna la montagna che con le sue
caratteristiche spaziali
in qualche maniera ci ha riempito di
creatività di vitalità possiamo dire
rabboccato la nostra energia
e mi rendo conto che queste parole
possano suonare un po romantiche la
montagna l'energia è però pensateci voi
come vi sentite
quando andate in montagna
a proposito di andare in montagna
c'è un oggetto che nell'immaginario
collettivo un po associamo
l'andare in montagna che cosa ci
portiamo quando si va a camminare sulle
spalle uno zaino dobbiamo fare uno zaino
premetto io ho una passione compulsiva
per farlo zaino
non so posso stare ore a comporlo
limarlo e come è come un bonsai una
sorta di diritto zen e in effetti
riflettendoci
fare uno zaino di quei pochi momenti
della nostra vita in cui siamo costretti
a identificare le essenziale per
evidenti limiti di spazio di peso che le
nostre spalle possiamo sopportare
e al contempo fare uno zaino ci
costringe a identificare
tutto ciò che è superfluo
la vedete io penso che in qualche
maniera
vivere in montagna
sia un po come fare uno zaino
da una parte la montagna ci mette
davanti a dei limiti ben precisi limiti
di spazio
di persone di servizi di lussi
vivere in montagna non ha le comodità
che offre la città non c'è il centro
commerciale
non c'è la movida ad esempio quando
nevica bisogna aspettare che che
puliscono le strade perché non c'è la
metro
e al contempo la montagna ti obbliga a
fare i conti con il tuo essenziale il
tuo essenziale e questo significa in
qualche maniera anche fare i conti con
con te stesso con quelle domande un po
ingombranti tipo che cosa conta
che cosa ti fa stare bene l'aria pulita
o centro commerciale che cosa che cosa
vuoi mettere nello zaino perché sai uno
spazio è lo spazio è quello e dagli non
scatti
ora a scanso di equivoci
non esiste uno zaino giusto e uno
sbagliato ognuno le sue priorità
ok
e queste domande per farteli non è che
devi per forza andare in montagna puoi
far tele
dove ti pare anche adesso
qui però il più delle volte un po
scappiamo da queste domande allora la
montagna è semplicemente un facilitatore
ti costringe a farci i conti con queste
domande ti mette davanti dei limiti
dall'altra parte
forse e da quello che per te è
essenziale questo torno meno è quello
che è accaduto a me in questo viaggio
quando abbiamo concluso la spedizione
metaforicamente parlando ho aperto il
mio zaino e l'ho trovato molto più
leggero di quello con cui ero partito
come se
tanti presunti bisogni
siano come evaporati superflui e dentro
c'era solo quello che per me è
essenziale
la consapevolezza di quello che mi sta
intorno di chi mi sta intorno
il contatto con la natura
e il tempo
il tempo per me per fare le cose che
chiamo fare questo è quello che io non
posso rinunciare
di tutte queste parole che cosa
che cosa ci rimane
diciamo che guardando la domanda
iniziale perché perché mai dovresti
pensare di vivere in montagna
più che altro ha seminato delle ipotesi
dei dubbi
ti senti smarrito allora forse potreste
approfittarne per realizzare qualcosa di
nuovo e sperimentale
forse la montagna può essere il
lavoratore ideale
forse
io vorrei soltanto
augurare a tutti noi di trovare la
nostra direzione che la nostra direzione
non rimanga soltanto un disegno sulla
mappa
però per farlo dobbiamo cercare uscire e
e cercare ognuno deve fare i conti
con il suo zaino e con le sue domande
c'è una poesia di brecht che
ama profondamente durante il viaggio nei
momenti più complessi critici mela
ripetevo un po per per incoraggiarmi e
termina con un verso
molto potente
non aspettarti nessuna risposta
oltre la tua
lo dice brecht io non ho risposte per
voi
figuratevi sto cercando le mie risposte
e mentre che cerco le risposte
sto anche cercando casa perché a furia
di vagare il girovagare
benevenuto un gran bisogno neanche una
gran voglia di scoprire se le sensazioni
di cui ho parlato
le sensazioni che provo lassù camminando
possono valere anche di venderci lassù
e quindi anzi se se qualcuno di voi
magari si sa di una casa in appennino
beh mi faccio sapere d'accordo
[Applauso]
[Musica]